big upset weekend boys oh big upset what
do you think
okay it's not what i think it's what i
want okay
every it seems as if
this is nate diaz's last fight on his
contract yeah right and nate diaz has
had this tumultuous relationship with
the ufc it's been incredibly lucrative
for the ufc and i'm sure nate yeah but
at the same time you know there's been
issues between them bickering
and um
it feels as if for his last fight
instead of them giving him like a tomato
can so he can go out on a win right
they're like yo we're going to give you
someone who might beat your ass which is
hamza okay right there's a highly touted
prospect though hamza had a really tough
fight with gilbert burns this last one
that i think took a little bit of shine
off
um
nate is fighting at 170 not fighting at
155 for this fight and hamzad can barely
make 170. he's probably more normal than
like 185 but he fights at 170 as well
so nate
everybody's writing adolf but at the
same time it's nate yeah you know what i
mean like you gotta you literally gotta
you know
stop like knock him out kill him to get
him out of there yeah i mean so what
happened with the leon edwards fight i
don't know if you guys saw that but like
leon was winning the fight and then with
literally less than a minute left nate
catches him wobbles leon leon's the
champion right now and like wobbles him
and like could have almost finished him
well that's what i was going to say
about leon leon won this one against
usman right yeah i'm getting the names
right yeah cause i everybody says oh you
can always catch it in one second
but i've never seen it to see usman
dominating the fight yeah and then with
30 seconds left get [ __ ] knocked out
and lose the belt it's like oh [ __ ]
there's really you can go at any time
and that's why we love the sport yeah
but it's yeah everybody it's like i
think emotionally i think we all want
nate to win yeah he's just one of those
people he's great yeah you just love him
yeah he seems super real super authentic
super yeah he's comfortable making you
uncomfortable he don't give a [ __ ] yeah
we're drawn to people who don't give a
[ __ ] despite it costing them yes because
most of us give a [ __ ] because if we
don't it costs and he's just saying [ __ ]
you to everybody yeah and it's kind of
cool to see
and uh it would be crazy if in his last
fight he's so sick he beats up and he
wins against
the
new prospect at the ufc nobody more
highly touted at the ufc right now yeah
than hamza you just can't bet against
dagestanis bro any muslim fighter bro
i've always said this bro i swear muslim
fighters are the are the best like they
there is just a there's a dedication bro
yeah from the jew here yep i like her
i'm not betting against yeah
like i even think historical wars
muslims probably got the highest body
count really like they're the best at it
like chinese dude but they're not
fighting for their reasons
come on they're not fighting for the
religious chinese right gangsters
genghis khan mongolian yeah but maybe
they were muslim i don't know i have no
idea if you count him then yeah i mean
he was a con you know i mean it was a
con yeah exactly but yeah i don't use
can't bet against islam
yeah no they're they're doing great
those dagusanis are absolutely killing
it but at the same time like i don't
know sometimes stories are
are are destined to happen a specific
way and i wonder if that's that's
on the line for this one not even that
oh damn that's how fire nate diaz is he
can have a pay-per-view event there's no
belts it's just we just want to watch
something yeah they made up about
they're like all right yeah ham and
i love it man so we'll see what happens
i don't know i mean it's an interesting
card there's a lot of interesting [ __ ]
they just added uh they just added a
poirier to the november 12th card you're
telling me that yeah michael chandler
are gonna fight and that's the one
that's right here at the garden we gotta
go to that izzy he's gonna be headlining
that [ __ ] yeah yeah so that's gonna be a
question they had that fight like were
they expecting to have dude the ufc is
[ __ ] amazing it's like
you know how boxing they'll be like one
interesting fight or one fight that
you're like aware of
the ufc will put five fights that you're
really interested in the card oh yeah
and it's awesome you end up watching the
whole card you feel like you got your
money's worth you're not spending 75 to
watch a two pounds heavy racing match
you're like okay i care about this i'm
gonna pay a bunch of money then watch a
bunch of bums on the undercard yeah if
you hear about an undercard in a boxing
match you're i'm again i'm very casual
but i'm like astonished i'm not like a
good undercard fanatic yeah i never
watch underground a lot of times but
that's order the pay-per-view and you
just come at 11 30. well you know
ufc you're watching guys that you have
no [ __ ] clue who they are they still
got day jobs they're fighting
on the undercard they don't matter yeah
cause one of them's gonna have an insane
like spinning [ __ ] elbow knock out
and you're like oh my god this is
craziest thing i've ever seen and they
all know that they're one exciting
knockout away from being a star yeah i
mean the fight of the night i wonder i
would want to see stats how often does
it it's always like like a random
undercard people don't really know about
yeah he always gets fire tonight i also
love the bonus structure that they have
where it's like it really incentivizes
guys
like you get this like 50 000 if i
knocked this guy out yeah you never
coast with somebody yeah yeah if you got
someone close to out of there you
getting him the [ __ ] out of there where
in boxing there were guys who were kind
of known for like what's called carrying
fighters
i'm gonna out point this guy we're gonna
go 12 rounds i don't need to change his
life in a bad way i don't need to get
him i don't need to take the risk to get
him out of here late in his career floyd
right 100 yeah now you can't incentivize
450 grand when he's making 100 million a
fight but like it would be crazy i
guarantee there'll be a lot more
knockouts in boxing if you doubled their
[ __ ] salary yeah for the knockout
before the exciting fight yeah but they
added this fight just to i guess like
boost value for the card or something i
think
or it's gonna be such a watch card that
you want to promote these fighters on it
maybe it's the upside of ufc always
having to worry about its product
whereas like a fighter is just worried a
boxer just worried about my boxing match
i don't give a [ __ ] about the wbc yeah
ufc is like how do we keep people
interested in the ufc let's stack every
card as much and ufc is the promoter of
every fighter on the card yeah whereas
with a boxing match you're the promoter
of the main card maybe some maybe half
of the fighters but you would never
fight your fighters against one another
yeah because that's her diminishing like
your product oh yeah yeah right but the
ufc realized like people don't really
care if you lose as long as they like
you
and they'll just keep watching you tony
ferguson's on this i think he's lost
three or four straight yeah by like
brutal knockouts
yeah i'm watching yeah i'm a wife i
probably won't pay for that guy that's
it
so yeah i don't know i gotta i gotta
rock with nate i just [ __ ] with nate and
let's see he's he's the most flagrant
fighter yeah he's gotta be here there's
one it's him 100 if he actually wins
what does he do negotiates for a big
ufc apparently he's starting his own
promotion or he just filed for
uh for uh like some paperwork or
whatever to like create his own
promotion or is he watching the uh
news for jake and anderson
like what kind of money he could make
100 percent yeah he would do that who
which one which brother would he fight
that's right jake and anderson got
announced too
late october yeah and you know it was
interesting about that i've never seen
jake so respectful in a in a promo video
i thought it was actually really cool it
was really cool to see like he did like
the
the little spider i'm gonna respect the
legend he must be exterminated yeah i'm
gonna exterminate the spider or whatever
which is fine but but he gasses him up
he's just like this guy is the [ __ ]
goat of this he's like he says all his
stats before i never seen jake promote a
fight like this so it was just an honor
to get in the ring no but it's also he's
a fighter and the promoter he needs some
people to understand build up the person
the fact that he's going in the ring is
wild now here's the thing champ anderson
silva yes he's 48 years old
but
he was just in there with julio cesar
chavez jr yeah okay this is a few years
removed but like who i think held like a
fringe belt at like 100 maybe 60 or 168
boxer knocked him out
i think he won decision oh really yeah
but he wanted i think he won one more
reason ortiz
yeah you know
he's the [ __ ] out yeah that's crazy but
to me it's more interesting
the guy you when you're in there with an
actual boxer and he's had actual this
will be jake's hardest fight without a
doubt yeah and they'll fight and if he
beats him they'll find a way to
discredit him but well he's 48 years old
that's the anderson silva is one of the
greatest mma fighters in history and
specifically strikers yeah in mma like
phenomenal and a southpaw
like this is big risk but i think
there's gonna be a lot of interest i
think it was the perfect person for him
to fight yeah did you see the thing he
was doing with dana to to announce it
what'd he say
this [ __ ] was clever bro but he was just
like look i don't need to promote this
fight i'm to let dana promote it for me
and then plays a video of dana being
like yo anderson silva he's the best
fighter of all time best mma like he's
the king he'll never fight anderson and
literally goes jake will never fight
jake why don't you call him out jake
jake where are you jake like
antagonizing him it's a great video and
then it comes back to jake and he goes
dana dana
i don't know it's like such good like
lore that was also interesting is he
wouldn't make silva the heel but he
needs somebody to do it
to me it was a little like is jake a
little nervous about this one because
you're not gonna talk [ __ ] about this
guy well i'll talk [ __ ] about danica i'm
gonna fight dana but this guy yeah oh
you're one of the ghosts it's an honor
to be in the ring i'm still gonna win
but yeah so i was like yo this guy seems
a little nervous for the first time dude
oh you think he's nervous about selling
maybe maybe i don't know if he beats
silva he has my respect really yeah
finally
he's earned your respect you know i
think that's what he's doing
he called me before he's like i'ma show
you right
you don't think they'll try to take it
away from him based on age they're 100
they will yeah he's washed up fights
someone in their primes
i'm not saying i will do this but this
is what people also do oh i'll respect
you if you beat this guy then you beat
this guy that guy was 49.
there's i'm interested to see him get
down in weight i mean they're fighting
at like 187.5 pounds or something like
that but like
jake probably walks around like 200 yeah
so this is gonna be i think his first
fight where he has to cut for mm-hmm
okay yeah let's see how that affects you
you know yeah like cutting weight
it's it you know things start loosening
it up is it two-month turnaround pretty
quick is that true it's under yeah well
jake was already in camp i think it's
harder for silva that's my thing that's
my question like why is silva taking
this like with short notice i think well
one there's obviously a payday two
i think that like when you're a fighter
and you've been fighting for that long
you're always kind of a few weeks out of
shape it's an eight-round bout it's not
like a 12-round bout
and uh so he probably has the confidence
that he can do it and like he i think he
trains his son yeah he seems like the
type that's always strange yeah it
probably isn't like he lives it yeah
yeah yeah so we're gonna see what
happens yo sports is back bro yeah i
don't know sports [ __ ] back
football nfl's back i'm hyped okay
cowboys are gonna be terrible but i'm
hyped about everything else oh really i
just here's what i'm starting to finally
wrap my mind around as i'm old as [ __ ]
if your offensive line is not set you're
not going to be in good shape that's why
i don't have faith in the bucks because
their offensive line is just decimated
with injuries
the chiefs they lost tyree kill but i
don't think that matters because they
fortified remember why they lost the
super bowl remember patrick mahomes
couldn't get any [ __ ] time against
tom brady in the bucks that's why they
lost brady's amazing but like that's why
they lost so i think the chiefs got a
real shot everybody's picking the bills
i'm not fully sold on the bills why is
there just because
i well because they were so good last
year they were probably better than the
chiefs and i don't know if you remember
was legitimately the craziest football
game i've ever seen in my life the
bills and chiefs and when they lost that
i hope i'm wrong because i love the i
love josh allen i want the city of
buffalo to get a ring ever sometime in
their life but like i just don't know if
you recover from that i would love to be
wrong but i just think if you they've
already beaten them basically every time
and then to lose like that i don't think
you recover yeah and i'm also wary of
the team everybody's picking and
everybody's picking the bills i feel
like that happens every single year yeah
oh it's the most dominant team by week
four there's injuries going crazy and so
i think the chiefs are still the team to
worry about i think the ravens are
always a wild card just because they're
just a great organization they always
draft well jackson is good they're set
at every position and this is lamar's
last year
of his contract you know what's
interesting is he's going no agent
representing himself in his and his
contract is expiring so he's playing for
200 million dollars or
i'm basically fighting for whatever i
can get back up job
like if he's good this year the ravens
have no choice but to sign him why is he
doing that
he just decided at some point i'm not
going to have an agent take 10 i'm going
to bet on myself 10
agent yeah in football in sports it's
like two or three huh
really yeah
i'm going by hollywood rules yeah no
that's why it doesn't make sense for me
it's because in
the uh the work for an agent to do
especially in like certain sports where
like the salary cap has all these things
built in it's like much less you have a
lawyer do it for most people yeah right
like what is it what is it this says
generally a sports agent earns between
four and ten percent of athletes playing
contracts though some league place
limits on what percentage the agent can
charge
yeah i would look up like football or
basketball specifically i thought it was
like two or three
yeah for example the nfl states that an
agent can receive more than three
percent of players salaries oh
interesting yeah three percent don't
they make but then it goes back once in
endorsements they'll they'll go back to
their normal formula so that's where
they make the bulk yeah but even then if
it's my contract here endorsements are
the same what
yeah no you can't regulate that
the point sorry to interrupt but it's
just so competitive that the other
agency is like yeah we'll just take
three percent sure we'll take three
we're talking about like
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars like the amount of actors that
exist in the world that can make this
kind of money is
there almost none so they're willing to
take much less for more of these clients
understandable for contracts but
there are only certain marquees look it
up so we don't have to hear him talk
anymore
about something he has no [ __ ] clue
about i can't wait so like what
uh
endorsement uh agent uh commission
anyway
but uh yeah that's crazy actually if
it's because if he's good again you have
to pay him 200 million dollars
and guarantee most if not all of it yeah
and if he's not good
that's it you're gonna be a backup
you'll sign you for a few million or
some team will take a flyer on you for
5-10 million wouldn't that still be the
case even with an agent but i think an
agent can also fight for you and protect
you in ways that you don't know to be
protected like i think a good agent
early on you remember when he was
getting drafted he was black so
people were like oh playing my wide
receiver he's not gonna be a good
quarterback i think an agent can be like
yo he's not playing for your team if you
don't have him be a quarterback i guess
he could say the same thing but he'll
just say the same thing an agent has the
credibility to be like
you're gonna have to trust me and the
same reason we have agents in our
business is so there's so many crazy
people that agents are like now this guy
is legit it's just me i'll fight for you
are really valuable to friend for fringe
players
so for example let's say that you're
like a mid-level player and you have an
agent yeah that's really powerful i can
see the value in that but if you're top
qb it's like like i'm just gonna go for
example like there's basketball players
i think ray allen didn't use an agent
for his max contract he knew he was
gonna get max contract all the
stipulations are already put in the
collective bargaining agreement decides
them so he just i think got a lawyer and
then he paid the lawyer a fee on it or a
much smaller i don't even think it was a
percentage i think it was just a flat
fee
got his all in deal the lawyer just
looks at whatever the last person to
sign a max contract and then just went
with it well this is also a little
different in that the ravens when you
get a rookie in the first round you can
pick up their option you get a four-year
deal they have an option for a fifth
year and after year two or three you can
say hey let's just send him now let's
just extend him now let's not [ __ ]
around the ravens didn't do that then
they decided all right we're still after
the fourth year we're not going to sign
him to an extension we'll just pick up
his option on his fifth year so now he's
legit in his last year of his deal
and this is it if he doesn't
if he doesn't play his ass off
somebody will sign him but it's hundreds
of millions of dollars he's losing you
look at this right go go go go go sports
agents generally receive between four
and 15 percent of athletes playing
contracts i just asked well right now we
just found out that okay it's two
percent hold on three
say three say four
but ten to twenty percent of athlete's
endorsement contracts which was my point
i was making it's different for
endorsements so [ __ ] you but also
question follow-up for you
that was good question
tampa bay does tom brady play better
with or without giselle in his life
since they're not talking right now is
that the deal
the rumor
is that
she is uh they're they're fighting
avocados he's really pissed that he
unretired yeah he's apparently like
[ __ ] livid that he's unretired there
there she just went to florida but
there's everyone is still saying they're
still
apparently that's why he took the ten
days i don't know if y'all know this
during training he just left for 11 days
yeah tom brady don't leave ever he don't
leave and then he blamed it on being 45.
and then when he said i'm 45.
i'm 45 guys i've got a lot of [ __ ] going
on which doesn't mean i'm 45. he meant
to say i'm married i got a lot of [ __ ]
going on yeah yeah but you can't say
that so you say i'm 45 let you read and
i'm married but a lot of people think
yeah he's fighting with makes him so
much more likeable yeah you hear these
like he's fighting with his wife
like tom brady yeah yeah yeah yeah
what happened to if you're explaining
you're losing
remember you were doing some explaining
right sometimes you got to lose buddy
yeah i i i don't know like i kind of
i i see where she's coming from a little
bit a little bit you 45 years old you've
achieved you're the greatest athlete
ever you've achieved everything infinite
money has never been more gay in your
life
it's not
a [ __ ] it's not acting it's not standard
your brain is on the line oh yeah like
all the time you're drinking out of a
[ __ ] straw for the rest of your life
choosing to do this yeah and she you
know like he brought her to tampa
you think that giselle wants to live in
tampa that's not the worst yeah it's
like living in cleveland
in new england
can i say something this is very
important to understand boston she makes
more money than her that's true
okay so that's why he's still playing
he's like [ __ ] i'm a catcher
real tough that's motivation with the
prenup i'll quit
it's on her that's one thing
she there i don't know this year maybe
he has some crazy thing or whatever but
there were many years that they were
together where she was making more money
and also he took very small contracts
from the patriots like he could have i
think got like 30 million a year yeah
and said he was taking like 12 so they
could build the team instead of he
wouldn't be the lowest but he'd be you
wouldn't be the highest paid player in
the league like he could have yeah
because he wants a better team around
him because he's the goat
but for her she don't have that chiang
got no teammates he's a supermodel son
you got all the money in the world you
got beautiful kids you can move out of
tampa and then all of a sudden he's like
nah we're gonna stay in tampa if if they
didn't live in tampa it'd be all right
stop right now it's not that bad i
guarantee you there's no it's tampa bro
name another franchise
franchise
what's that
there's also leaves you don't want to
have to fill your pump up with leaves
are you kidding me
what are you talking about
this is they're the richest people in
tampa i'm going to say
you think it's where you think giselle's
scooping leaves out of the view you play
for the rams he thinks the pool is above
ground for this guys
so [ __ ] no you can't afford a pool
cover they could do anything you know
where i heard he wanted to go was the
raiders in las vegas or miami yeah i
already wanted to leave tampa this year
if they're in miami she has no problem
they're in miami you go to the rams like
those are the only places
to live if she's in if they're in la
play until you're 65 i don't give a [ __ ]
if they're in miami playing through your
six fight i don't give a [ __ ] they're in
new york playing through 65 i don't give
a [ __ ]
boston maybe
nah right
nah that's why he left that [ __ ]
brazilian gisele is like from brazil
right like she doesn't [ __ ] with cold
like that's not gonna happen yeah yeah
yeah it's gotta be miami or outlet i
think the new york they could pull it
off yeah but she don't [ __ ] with swamp
either
bro it's really tampa's fault all right
so does he play better or worse
depending better plays better uh-huh if
the line heals up you'll be fine i don't
know if the line will heal up but if the
line heals up you'll be great i just
don't know that they will it's going to
be a rough first month for sure he's
saying based on the relationship i know
but if the line heals up he'll be better
but thanks for answering like a geek
yeah which one you're talking about
don't understand her you're like
i don't understand what you're coming
from bro
some more andrew tate as soon as you
take his band this guy's like i get
women stop it bro what happened to you i
missed the old answer this is why you
need him off the internet bro
he got you in check okay that's the fact
that you're getting all gay look the
point is um i'm going with nate okay i'm
going with uh
gisele i'm putting money on giselle yeah
um okay yeah i bet huh yo i bet
tom don't make it through the season bro
oh wow they don't put an injury on it no
no no buy giselle oh injury
do you think he pulls
jumping jacks took the stairs to the
studio today this [ __ ] got liz
frank whatever the [ __ ] i've been
running sprints
no dude oh my god
i honestly don't even think you hurt
your ankle yeah
i'm great i'm fine i just needed out of
bernie anyway um
bet online.ag they're gonna match your
initial deposit bonus fifty percent of
it up to a thousand dollars that means
you put in a thousand they will give you
500 extra what you could gamble with
you didn't want to be dollars okay you
could bet on giselle winning
you could bet on nate winning you could
bet on hamzad you can bet on anything
plenty of [ __ ] to do on the biggest in
the business bet online.ag make sure you
use that promo code flagrant when you do
it to get that initial deposit bonus
all right peace